welcome to this video playing starry
buck and then definitely promise that i
will look at this is Croatia or some
yeah this is Croatia I will definitely
look this up it's really embarrassing
that I cannot tell those four legs apart
okay we get a king's indian fianchetto
trying them something else he's playing
with d6c 6 lettuce is called the Cavalla
variation if i'm not mistaken okay with
Queen 85 like now place Bishop g4 or e 5
those two possibilities um okay White
has gotten the bishop pair here it's
quite nice and to know black normally
plays v5 sooner or later here we go now
white now has two basic possibilities
you can play d5 keeping the position
closed or can keep the tension keeping
the tension is so I think the more
ambitious option but I also think that
this kind of position with them close
center is quite nice for wired I have
study ahead study to this this opening
line for black button some some time ago
but ultimately didn't like it so much
because you have some problems with
their with peace activity so difficult
for black to get active King h7 Bishop
h6 is a typical way to play but white
can play g-form intending to play g5 and
this is a key problem for black and now
i have g5 and Bishop to g4 and this is a
key problem for black this is a very
active Bishop here on G form
looking at the important square as d7
and see aid sticking I'm taking a moment
going back to g8 okay so let's put it on
g-form not overthinking thanks here okay
um probably Roxy one attending night a
form one way to play using the weekend
squares here okay he's trying to to open
open this this up still night a form I
wonder this also know if was probably
not a great idea you know this is
probably just good intending to take on
d7 play Knight b6 not quite sure what is
responses now that looks them looks very
annoying okay rook c8 I take not be six
wins the house be five maybe be five
Bishop d7 be a four-man this this could
be could be what is playing
okay so let's think about this maybe
there is open there is some other some
other way to play I'm thinking about
Roxy sexy actually Roxy 6ba for look d 6
but this is this is just simple simple
and good I think I hope okay um he must
take the question is what now Queen g4
maybe the sir looks quite good in
attacking h 4f 5 I take a jetta cage for
me I can take f5 this is some in fact in
fact to be determined I take edge for
and you play something to age 6 I cannot
take it because of the pin but I can
take here right Queen takes descend
there's the capture on g6 winning the
Queen so I'm now threatening to take on
h4n to take on g6 the should should end
this game black resigned yeah I lost I
don't like this line at awful black I
mean I years ago I thought it would be
quite interesting strategically because
black if Black gets this Bishop g7 to be
exchanged then he's not in bad shape but
it's it's difficult to do simply always
because of this this G for business
around here Black is already in a very
critical state king age 7 is probably
not a good move as
Bishop age six is the idea of course but
you simply don't get to play it and
after G for now it's jeff very hard now
to do to continue you don't want to take
as it opens up the H file but what
exactly is your move I played H form
yeah and now g5 Bishop g4 this is
tremendous for wide and it's quite quite
remarkable the computer here stockfish
is on plus form with f4 actually yes I'm
I was briefly considering this F form
just going for King side attack which
which much might be very valid them but
not a for loop don't see one looked
simple and strong what is he doing here
rook checks yes hmm yeah threatening to
take take on h4 and curtains yeah plus
4y this totally winning M is also very
good this is not as convincing it's very
very good for white but not so
convincing f6 night a form it's still
plus three years so it's not like I i
made some some huge mistake here Queen
g4 I mean wins but Bishop f5 is a very
that's a very aesthetic move to play
very very nice move Queen h5 is the
threat and the black takes get the check
here check and wince the Queen very nice
yeah but it's a good multiple ways to
win this here you take seventh and he
resigned as Queen takes check loses the
house probably be made later and yeah
simply no move against this and this
thread so I think this this whole line
him with them sorry I did this wrong
here
this this whole line I don't think is
very attractive for for black it's very
one-sided position okay thanks for
watching